المعين الخاص من وزارة
الشؤون الخارجية للاتحاد
روسيا في حركات المنظمات
الشخصيات الاجتماعية الرائدة
ذهب التين السياسي الممثل ستيفن سيجال
موجودة في جمهورية البوليفارية
فنزويلا نسلم ل
على وجه التحديد في نوفمبر 2016 قبل
جزء من الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين و
2018 كممثل خاص لـ
وزارة الخارجية في
صور رئيس الدولة الفنزويلي
مناورة بعد نيكولاس مادورو
يعطيه المور هذا السيف المهم
من اللوائح التي تصدق على ذلك بالضبط
الأخوة بين فنزويلا وكذلك
الاتحاد الروسي دعونا نتذكر أن
ممثل معترف به في 2018 فرنسا
السلام البوليفاري بهذه الطريقة مع
تقديس شباب الاتحاد
هوية جمهورية فنزويلا
البوليفارية من فنزويلا خارج
حدودنا زائد واحد فقط
فنزويلا ستشارك أيضا في
هؤلاء الخبراء الفنيون هم مسيرة
الذي كان بطل الفيلم
العمل مع تاريخ طويل و
ضمن فيلمه بالفعل عند الخروج
رئيس الدولة الفنزويلية يقيل
ضيف مقدمة إلى السلطة التنفيذية الوطنية
ولكن هذا بالإضافة إلى أنني أقوم بتأمين Moors لـ
الخروج من هذا الاجتماع المهم أن
لقد أبرزنا الدبلوماسية
السلام البوليفاري